problema 132 nos dicen que en es un
entero mayor que 1 n entero
pero mayor que uno y la pregunta o lo
que lo que tenemos que determinar es si
n es igual a 2 vale en el inciso 1 en el
inciso 1 la información que nos dan es
que n tiene exactamente dos factores
positivos entonces n dos factores
actores positivos
positivos
pensemos tantito si esto es suficiente
pues claro que no verdad en realidad los
números que tienen dos factores
positivos positivos son los números
primos por ejemplo n podría ser 3 y sus
factores serían sus factores serían 1 y
o tal vez 7 y sus factores serían 1 y 7
o incluso puede ser 2 2
y sus factores serían 1 y 2 sale
entonces no podemos determinar si em es
igual a 2 o no porque hay muchos números
que tienen dos factores positivos y que
no son dos vale bueno ahora vamos al
inciso 2 en el inciso 2 nos dice que la
diferencia de cualesquiera dos factores
positivos de n es impar oral esto está
bien extraño a ver la diferencia
diferencia
de cualesquiera dos factores de dos
factores
o sea cualesquiera dos factores cuando
los restemos nos da un impar
impar
bar
ok está condición está muy fuerte a ver
déjame pensar un poco qué quiere decir
a ver ahí te va una idea qué sucede ahí
te va la pregunta qué sucede
qué sucede
si n si n tiene
más de dos factores más de dos factores
actor es lo que estoy intentando hacer
es mostrar que la información del inciso
1 está contenida en el inciso 2 vale
entonces nada más con la información del
inciso 2 vamos a pensar qué sucede si n
tiene más de dos factores entonces tiene
al menos tres factores digamos a b y c
sale uno de ellos es uno otro de ellos
es n y puede haber otro más vale
entonces si tiene más de dos tiene al
menos tres factores pero si tiene tres
factores como son tres tiene que haber
dos con la misma paridad 2 con
la misma misma variedad
caridad
sale 2 con la misma paridad es decir si
éste es par y éste es impar pues este
sea lo que sea ya va a repetir verdad
vamos a tener dos pares o dos impares
a fuerza debe haber dos que tengan la
misma paridad pero al restar esos dos
que tienen la misma paridad obtendríamos
un número par contradiciendo esto vale
va otra vez si tenemos al menos tres
factores dos de ellos tienen la misma
paridad pero entonces la resta sería par
y no podríamos tener lo que nos dice el
inciso 2 entonces qué sucede si n tiene
más de dos factores tiene
tiene dos factores dos factores
con resta par con resta
re está bien diferencia
y entonces no se podría verdad entonces
es imposible que en este caso tengamos
más de dos factores de modo que sabiendo
la información de este inciso nada más
así solito podemos concluir el inciso 1
es decir que n tiene dos factores dos
factores
a actor es bueno tiene menos de 3 pero
no puede tener uno porque n es mayor que
1 entonces n tiene dos factores dos
factores y por lo tanto n debe ser un
número primo n es primo
pero pero n 1 es una resta de factores
verdad porque ny1 son factores de n y si
n fuera un primo impar un primo impar
menos 1 nos quedaría para lo cual otra
vez sería imposible
de modo que n sólo puede ser 2 n sólo
puede
en eso lo puedes ser 2 vale tiene fuera
un primo impar entonces p menos uno o n
uno sería impar vale lo cuales sería
para lo cual es una contradicción con
esto de acá entonces n debe ser igual a
2 para que dos menos uno sea impar
entonces esta información del inciso 2
está súper buena nos dice la información
del inciso 1 y además nos da la paridad
del número y por lo tanto podemos
concluir que el número es 2 que n es
igual a 2
entonces el inciso b por sí mismo si nos
permite responder la pregunta y el
inciso 1 no muy bien creo que este ha
sido el problema más padre que hemos
hecho de todos bueno todos están buenos
algunos un poco aburridos pero pero
bueno vamos al problema 133 en el
problema 133 nos dicen que cada miembro
de un cierto club voluntariamente decide
cooperar para la compra de un regalo de
60 pesos entonces hay un regalo
regalo de 60 pesos
que van a comprar entre los miembros de
un club y la pregunta es cuántos
miembros tiene el club cuántos miembros
déjame llamarle a eso m cuántos miembros
tiene el club y además dice que todos
cooperan lo mismo entonces a la
cooperación a la cooperación de cada
quien
operación de cada quien le voy a poner
se vale bueno entonces vamos a ver vamos
a ver qué información nos dan en el
inciso 1 lo que nos dice es que la
contribución de cada miembro es 4 vale
entonces sabemos que se es igual a 4 c
es igual a 4 lo que se cooperan entre
todos es c por m lo que coopera cada
quien por la cantidad de miembros
entonces sabemos que 60 sería igual a c
o sea 4 por m y de aquí podemos
determinar el valor de m verdad
simplemente dividimos entre 4 de ambos
lados y nos queda que m es igual a 15
entonces el inciso 1 es suficiente para
responder la pregunta vamos a ver qué
nos dice el inciso 2 a este se ve
emocionante dice si cinco miembros del
club no cooperan entonces lo que ahora
cada quien pone son dos pesos más
entonces cinco no cooperan no cooperan
y dice que lo que pone cada quien lo que
pone
cada quien
es dos pesos más dos pesos más
esto está interesante cómo podemos
pensar esto esto nuevo o esto adicional
que pone cada quien a pues simplemente
le ponemos que dos pesos es igual a
estos cinco en realidad cuánto tenían
que cooperar pues tenían que cooperar se
verdad como ya habíamos puesto aquí la
cooperación de cada uno ese entonces
estos dos pesos es que lo que pusieron
estos 50 más bien lo que ya no van a
estar poniendo dividido entre los
miembros que quedan entre m / m menos 5
vale entonces esto que debieron haber
cooperado esos 5 ahora se lo tienen que
repartir los m menos cinco restantes y
esos son los dos adicionales que pone
cada quien vale vamos a ver si con esto
nada más con la información del inciso 2
podemos responder la pregunta qué otras
cosas sabemos pues sabemos está esta
ecuación que no hemos apuntado verdad
que 60
es igual a m por c m
y esto parece ser casi un sistema lineal
si es un sistema lineal de ecuaciones no
estoy seguro a ver déjame hacerlo con
calma voy a pasar el m5 multiplicando me
quedaría 12 m menos 10 es igual a 5 c ah
no no es un sistema lineal porque aquí
nos quedaría despejándose que se es
igual a 60 / m simplemente dividido
entre m de ambos lados de modo que 12 m
menos 10 es igual a 5 por 60 o sea a 300
/ / m / / m simplemente tome este valor
de c y lo sustituye aquí y ahora
multiplicando por m de ambos lados me
quedaría que 2 m cuadrada 2 m cuadrada
menos 10 m es igual a 300
cientos y por lo tanto 2 m cuadrada
menos 10 m menos 300 es igual a 0
entonces no no es precisamente un
sistema lineal en dos variables más bien
salió en una ecuación cuadrática por
aquí pero igual podemos responder la
vamos a ver qué sucede déjame dividir
entre dos a ambos lados de la igualdad
me quedaría m cuadrada menos 5 m m
- ciento cincuenta 150 igual a cero y me
imagino que esto se puede factorizar a
ver me parece que es m
15 por m 10
m 10 15 por 10 es menos 150 menos 15 10
es menos 5
entonces las soluciones serían m 15 y m
igual a menos 10 pero un club no puede
tener menos 10 miembros entonces está la
eliminamos y de nuevo obtenemos un valor
de m entonces este inciso por sí mismo
también nos permite responder la
pregunta de modo que la respuesta sería
de de muy bien vamos ahora el problema
134 problemas 134 en color color verde
entonces problemas 134 en este problema
nos dicen que m y n son son enteros
positivos m y n enteros
positivos
vivos y lo que tenemos que determinar es
si raíz de n - m es
déjame poner la raíz un poco más bonita
raíz
dn - m es es entero
entero
muy bien en el inciso número 1 lo único
que nos dicen es que n es mayor que m +
15 en términos de n
m esto quiere decir que n gm le gana a
15 pero esto no nos garantiza que la
raíz de nm cms a entera verdad porque nm
podría ser 16 y su raíz sería 4 o podría
ser 17 y raíz de 17 no es un entero
entonces esta de acá no nos da
información suficiente no nos da
información suficiente y el inciso 2 lo
que nos dice es que n es igual a m por m
1 o sea es igual a m cuadrada más m y
qué sucede si este valor de n lo
sustituimos aquí arriba nos quedaría que
raíz o más bien tendríamos que averiguar
raíz de m cuadrada
m - m muy bien m se cancelaría con m nos
quedaría raíz de m cuadrada lo cual es
igual a m porque mes entero positivo
positivo y aquí si quedo entero si quedó
justo m que es entero entonces el inciso
2 sí nos permite determinar si esto es
entero o no y justo queda que si es
entero entonces la respuesta sería b
únicamente el inciso 2 sirve para
responder la pregunta